there are people watching the red carpet
Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton serving
up all the cuteness on their latest date
night
[Music]
the duo hit the red carpet Tuesday night
at the premiere of Bennett's war in
Burbank California and there was no
holding back on the PDA
[Music]
Gwen and Blake posed hip-to-hip with
their arms around each other and check
out this shot of the make me like you
singer lovingly gazing at her bow her
usual Gwen's fashion was on point
I mean no one can rock army chic quite
like her Blake on the other hand kept it
casual in jeans and a black collared
shirt at one point they were joined by a
friend did you record that yeah oh no
Gwen spotted country singer Trace Adkins
on the red carpet which she hilariously
documented on her IG stories here they
are hugging it out and posing it up with
him and Canadian actress Victoria Pratt
who both star in the movie hitting
theaters on August 30th I'm gonna lose
the farm son number on the mortgage
speaking of a mortgage Gwen and Blake
recently bought a house together and a
source tells et that they are loving
their life as a family with Stefani's
three sons 13 year old Kingston 10 year
old Zuma and six year old Apollo but
despite going strong since 2015 and
being head over heels in love our source
says the two aren't eager to jump into
marriage just yet
meanwhile the pair is busy filming their
show The Voice something our source says
they've had the best time doing together
adding quote they adore each other
working together is truly an ideal
situation for them
[Music]